starting off this hour is will in
Missouri hey well welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show hey Dave I doing better than
I deserved man
how can I help hey so you know I've been
watching some of your programs recently
and you do talk a lot about you know the
benefits of joining a good church I used
to be very devout Catholic
I recently fall out of the faith and my
question for you is do you think joining
a church has a long-term effect on your
financial and mental health well I don't
know if I've got a doctrinal answer all
I can tell you is what I have against
okay what I have personally experienced
is it's had a profound effect on my life
now you have to put the caveat the
asterisks there that anytime there's a
gathering of people you're gonna find
some idiots and that includes church
right you're gonna find some toxic
people you're going to find some mean
people some bitter people some angry
people anytime there's a gathering of
people you're going to find that and
church is not exempt from that I think
sometimes folks might go to a church and
think well all the people over there a
perfect number one I wouldn't be welcome
because I'm not perfect but then number
two you know then they have this
expectation that these that this set of
humans is somehow you know never going
to mess up or never going to make you
angry you're never going to hurt your
feelings or never do something wrong and
they do all the time I mean I've been
but I start going to church as an adult
so I didn't I didn't have the whole
upbringing thing and so for me you know
admittedly some of the more frustrating
times and some of the things that have
made me the angriest and most
disappointed are some of the human
beings there but but I've also found
some of the best people on the planet
there and I've also personally for me I
mean everybody has their own thing but
all I can talk about is what happened to
me what happened to me it's where I
learned how to be a better dad it's
where I learned how to be a better
husband it's where I learnt how to be a
better leader spiritual growth and faith
in God
has revolutionized my life now some
people they have not had that experience
I understand but I'm talking about me
that's what happened to me so I I mean
sharing often jokes we've been married
38 years she's really thankful she's not
married to the same guy she started with
he you know that he has been transformed
because he was pretty much at work I
don't you know I don't exactly how I
talk to women into marrying me but I
will tell you this after 38 years I'm a
much better husband and I attribute some
of that to reading books on marriage
going to marriage counseling and
spiritual growth and learning about
marriage through the lens of spirit that
my spiritual walk in through Scripture
that's an example and you could talk
about leadership on that and you can
talk about raising your kids that way
you know do all kids who are raised by
parents who go to church turn out no
they don't all turn out I mean we all
know somebody's kid who hit the wall you
know I mean that's part of life but you
know but I did learn a lot about being
you know kind compassionate firm solid
dad and sticking through the process
from people of faith in the mix of the
Christian community in the mix of church
but you know I understand if you grew up
in a situation where you had a toxic
environment or something that it might
not be that is that is that what you're
asking
yeah so you know I was raised Catholic
and you know with that came a lot of
traditional values conservative them
conservatism sorry being one of them
and you know I'm kinda in college now
kind of finding my own way on with that
came a more diverse opinion of things
that did lead to some clashing with my
parents which is ultimately why I
decided to leave the faith but I was
just kind of asking so you left your
parents faith the faith you left your
parents faith yeah I mean I guess I if
the clash with your parents caused you
to not like God then you weren't like
you know you were you were only hooked
to them anyway right well I you know
basically I think I had a strong complex
of wanting to appeal
they're very strong traditional parents
so you know they said do you know do
what I say and make sure that you know
you're going to school and becoming what
we want you to be a little bit I wanted
to be a priest for a very long time kind
of because of their wishes so I guess
yeah it was more of a parents fallout
but I did stop going to church I did
stop practicing and I guess now it's
just kind of we're out I'm finding my
way back into it a little bit and I was
just calling it to see so maybe so yeah
I think you just find out I think you
find out for yourself now what what you
were really going for if you were just
going to make your daddy happy that's
that's not faith so you've got to find
your own now or not but you're just
defining that I'm just a old guy talking
to you I'm not a theologian dude you
probably know more about this if you
were studying to be a priest you
probably know more about this and I do
but it just you know from a relational
standpoint you're just a young guy
sounds like and in college and you know
you don't only get your political stand
and your faith confused those are not
they're not senescent they're not
synonymous you know they they do inform
some things if you believe in you know
the doctrines of your faith they're
going to inform some stands on in the in
the marketplace right
for instance Catholics have a very
strong pro-life agenda and believe very
Pro and so if you want to be you know
politically left on that subject is
you're gonna struggle with your
catherine a catholic doctrine because
they don't believe that you know yeah
the Pope Mother Teresa you know so on
have spoken very clearly on these issues
and very eloquently by the way and with
great persuasion but you know so that's
just an example but that that's where
politics will intersect your faith but
you don't have to say all Catholics are
conservatives or all evangelicals or
conservatives because they're certainly
not right right no so anyway I if I were
you I'd go look for your own what was it
that you were there for for you what
portion
of the hour that you sat there fed you
and was not there for your dad because I
think you have figured out very clearly
you're very self-aware or very wise
I appreciate your Kurt that it you know
you were somewhat living through their
faith their their umbilical cord and
that's been clipped now and so now
you've got to find your own connection
to God and when you find that it's gonna
be rich and deep cuz it'll be yours so
that that's kind of experience I had to
dude because I in the sense of I started
going to church as an adult I met God as
an adult and so you know it was a very
there's a very personal thing it wasn't
attached to my upbringing
the paradox you know perpendicularly or
what yours was so interesting discussion
I'm honored that she would ask me
something like that but um I'm probably
the last guy on the earth should be
commenting on it but I'm expert on my
opinion so I can always tell you what
happened to me and that's what happened
to me hey thanks for the call
good luck with that I'll pray for you